Out of
two music music legends
who knew and worked with Tina Turner.
Grammy Award
winner Ruth Pointer,
the last surviving member
of the Pointer
Sisters, whose
first album, I should say, Ruth
turns 50 this month.
I know
that is something on a sad day, though,
to think about it.
Incredible
to celebrate
your many hits
include I'm
So Excited
and Jump and Grammy Award winner
Bryan Adams
whose songs
you all know include everything I Do.
I do it for you and Run to you.
I am so grateful to have both of you
on to talk about
a woman
that you admired,
that you performed with,
who you consider a friend.
Ruth,
what did you first think when you heard
that Tina Turner had passed away today?
Oh, my God.
I just started weeping.
You know,
I, I loved her so much.
In my opinion,
she was my queen in the music industry.
She was my queen.
I wanted to be her.
You know,
I tried to be her with my sisters and I.
I saw her several times.
I actually saw her with Ike in Oakland
right after I graduated high school
at a little juke joint there in Oakland.
Sportsman's Club.
We used to go to with the cats, and
I was never the same after that.
But I've seen her concerts
and I saw her musical and
and we did The World Together, and
she's watched us perform at clubs.
I remember once her
standing up side of the stage,
we didn't even know she was there. Wow.
And they came and told us
that you've got a guest
that's watching you perform.
And we can say again, it was Tina.
And we just fell apart
and she said,
you guys look like for Tina.
Turner is up there on that stage
because we were tearing it up.
I can only imagine what that
moment must have been like.
I mean,
you know, you both worked with her
and perform with her.
Brian, you recorded a duet with her,
It's Only Love
and that was released in 1985.
You know, a lot of people have seen this,
but I just want to play it
and
I don't know.
And you worked together again, Brian,
when you wrote the song back
where you started
and you wrote that for her.
Here's here's part of that
And that song
she won
a Grammy in 1987
for best female rock vocal performance.
What memories can you share
Brian of working with her.
Well my god yeah right.
I'm
incredibly sad I've been all day today
since I read the news and
it's it's taken
a lot to actually even do this
interview because,
you know,
she was not only
really kind to me in the beginning, but
just fabulous to work for.
And I I'll tell you one story
which probably
nobody knows,
which is the story
when I recorded back
when you started with her
and she came into the studio and
we ran the song down quickly.
And I just
when I started talking to the engineer
and I said,
okay, listen,
this and I looked up, was it
Tina, can you.
And she left
and I,
I went running down the hall,
said, Tina, you.
Well, you need to do it again.
She goes, no, no, no.
On you guys
and we didn't quite get a boat,
but she did come back and we did it.
And then she won a Grammy for it,
which was absolutely incredibly
happy for her about.
But the thing about being with her
on tour was unbelievable
because as you can see, these
this live video
you're watching right now.
She asked me to come
and be her support
act in Europe back in 1985.
And it changed everything for me
as a solo performer.
It really opened up
everything and I will never ever be able
to articulate
how grateful I am to her for that.
So which is incredible
and shows
the generosity of spirit
and the ability to
to mentor
that, you know, people wouldn't know
unless you share that.
And if you worked with her
and of course, other music legends on
We Are the World in 1985,
which raised money for famine
relief in Africa and truly was iconic.
I mean something
I remember
is one of the first kind of core
musical memories of childhood.
Here's some of that iconic video
Ruth, do you have
any memories of working with her on that?
Oh, my God.
My fondest memory of her that night
we had a break and me, Tina,
Latoya Jackson
and Bette Midler were huddled in a corner
just chatting
like girls do about the guys.
And man,
I think
Bette Midler and I
were dating the same guy
we were
we were just talking about men
and their shenanigans and stuff.
And Tina was just standing there to,
you know,
we were just all
sort of chatting about guys,
but it was really special for me
just being among those.
And here,
I mean, again,
again, one of those things would
none of us can even imagine
being a fly on the wall.
Never mind what you felt,
if that's when you found out
you were dating the same guy.
But I assume
that would be a tell
for another conversation.
Brian,
let me play a bit
more of what Tina Turner said.
Her favorite song was the best.
Here's what she said. Just you
and Brian, I'm sorry.
That was the song.
But let me play
what she told Larry King about
why that song is her favorite
This is very special
because at the time when I got it,
no one believed in it but me and I.
I organized riding the horse.
That was a really struggle.
With Roger, my manager,
and the record company.
I thought,
well, what are you going to do
with a horse?
And the whole thing was it was a freedom.
I felt
I felt just riding
and that music in the back.
And that's a sign
and I felt it would be great for sport.
And it ended up in
many different countries for sport.
I mean, it just. Yeah.
Brian, do you have a favorite song
Tina Turner song
a favorite?
Well,
I mean, obviously the ones,
you know, that we work together on,
but I love that song.
Particularly because it was great,
great live
the Al Green song to stay together.
Beautiful.
You know, it was funny.
I was just thinking about this
Tina and I just remember that I
she asked me
to sing in her wedding with Irwin,
and I, I was,
it was in the back, in your backyard
and in your house.
And it was,
it was an amazing moment
to be singing for her.
And I kept thinking,
are you going to come up and help me
with this?
You know, Wow.
That was a great honor.
And, you know, this is,
this is the thing.
You know,
I really have a hard time
telling you everything that I know.
And the experiences I've had with her,
you know, because she was a friend and
well, look,
I'm sorry for both of you for your loss.
It's so
personal and it's so hard
to have a personal loss
when when everybody else
also feels that they touch it
because it's someone like her
who touched so many. So.
Thank you very much,
both of you,
for for taking the time
to share some of your memories
and bring her even more alive.
As a human to all of us. Thanks.
Thank you as well.
Yeah, thank you.
Love you
practiced law
and and
and there there's a deal right there.
We will look for that. Thank you.